a war on meat a plastic straw ban and
even calls for population control those
are just some of the extreme climate
change ideas 2020 Democrats are
proposing check out some of their bold
statements this UN report that says now
I guess it's 11 years that we have left
do you ban plastic straws I think we
should yes the UN just released a study
that said we're gonna be okay if the
vast majority the world goes vegetarian
immediately this is on par with winning
World War two perhaps even more
challenging than that the most
controversial moment of the night coming
from Bernie Sanders the socialist
senator igniting a firestorm for this
answer about cutting global population
growth to fight global warming the
Mexico City agreement which denies
American aid to those organizations
around the world that are that allow
women to have abortions or even get
involved in birth control to me is
totally absurd so I think especially in
poor countries around the world where
women do not necessarily want to have
large numbers of babies and where they
can have the opportunity through birth
control to control the number of kids
they have something I'd very very
strongly support all right let me just
phrase the question that he got from the
audience member the planet cannot
sustain this growth time a human
population I realize this is a poisonous
topic for politicians but it's crucial
to face empowering women and educating
everyone on the need to curb population
growth seems a reasonable campaign to
enact and she has if anyone would be
courageous enough to say so and I guess
Bernie Sanders said what he thought
Jesse courageously stupid I'd like to
first thank CNN for providing us this
amazing content which I'm going to mock
now the wigs and I believe the president
would also like to thank CNN for asking
some of these frontrunners specific
questions which they actually answered
for instance would you like to ban the
combustion engine yes would you like to
ban natural gas drilling yes would you
like to ban coal yes goodbye
Pennsylvania goodbye Michigan goodbye
Ohio but it gets better would you like
to ban offshore drilling yes
goodbye Florida and goodbye any chance
you'll ever have of flipping Texas blue
but it does get better
would you like to bend
factory farming yes goodbye Iowa and
goodbye Wisconsin so the answers were
stupid and the questions were amazing
for Republicans and everybody should
thanks and then the fact that they
actually got on there and said
depopulation control is crazy that's
what they do in communist China it's a
discredited theory in fact the shooter
and the last two mass shootings he he
has obscure that philosophy and now
they're also saying we should start you
know eating less meat get out of my
kitchen
what is this all of these ideas are just
gonna make everyone's life miserable
they're gonna cost trillions of dollars
and they're not gonna change the earth's
temperature one degree I think that
that's a very good point and Michael
Shellenberger was on earlier saying that
a very thing that if you take all the
things that they talked about most of
the things would actually increase
emissions of greenhouse gases including
if you want to do away with nuclear I
noticed you were shaking your head at
the Bernie Sanders one I just I can't
believe well of course Bernie's gonna
take this question I'll say it come on
we want to help you kill your children
it's crazy it's really crazy into what
you're saying like seven hours of this
on CNN seven hours it's like CNN is a
restaurant that somewhat like the Mafia
bought and they're burning it down for
the insurance money I don't know what
their ratings were like the future seems
so bleak like could it sound any worse
or what we all we all need to be
vegetarians living like it's World War
two drinking out of straws that don't
work
give me Trump anything of the week make
America great again I don't want to
leave in this this this is bleak
it's like The Hunger Games what they're
just describing now one would you like
to comment on the Bernie Sanders one or
do you want to hear about the hurricane
connection no I do
I let me comment on the whole thing cuz
I just I just find it such a distortion
I can't believe the things Jessie says
and says that these are like true they
didn't say these yes they did well then
you say watch and then Michael says o
kill babies nobody said anything like
that Joe Biden said he wants to ban the
combustion engine
and they want to get rid of offshore
drilling and eliminating coal fires
here's the here's the heart is really
response coming at this table
oh these Democrats they want to control
you they want to take away your straws
they don't want you to eat meat oh my
gosh you know it's this is just it's me
it's mind boggling one Democrats have
ideas boy Republicans have no ideas when
it comes to dealing with climate control
so what a Republican say oh those ideas
we're that ideas redic here come
Democrats saying let's talk about this
because guess what overwhelmingly it's
like 80% plus of Democrats and over 60%
of independents say climate change is a
big issue we want to deal with it it's
an emergency so here are some ideas none
of these ideas are radical by the way
how many farmers factory farming in fact
keep talking but I'm just telling you
what you go talk to farmers and they'd
say they prefer that they be less of
that factory big you're saying that all
the things that Jesse said sounds crazy
he repeated things that they said we ban
plastic straws bringing up abortion in
the context of a question about
population so you don't think that's
really not being talked about what is
the American taxpayer funded aborted is
it olive oil it's United States but
elsewhere let me just say this it's
illegal under the Mexico City agreement
right and then what you get is
Democratic presidents on going back here
to Clinton and Obama both said no to it
so it's not a new idea you don't be a
bush said oh exactly it's never been
about abortion it's about birth you
don't think talking about people should
convert to to veganism or vegetarianism
you don't think bringing up abortion in
the context of a conversation about
population control or banning fracking
or banning Placido did none of this
sounds extreme No
you didn't bring up abortion worries me
because how does an indication that the
Democratic Party you are the audience
for this there is an audience huge
audience we said once who seems
perfectly reasonable sometimes Thanks
right now it's sounding so extreme and I
am I'm not extreme sounds extreme Jessie
doesn't sound extreme to a law in the
country you think scary you thinking
banning the internal combustion engine
is a radical idea yeah okay well that's
what Joe Biden just saw what he said no
it's you're talking about our band like
eliminate nobody say he says he wants to
eliminate it in his turn he wants he
wants this is so odd Joe Biden what he
wants to do is have less and less
reliance on the back kind in the word go
towards alright a long weekend water to
world towards you know the idea that you
want to have a real discussion about
climate change it's just scary to you
because it would say you have no idea
reporter Florida I heard you say Florida
Oh Florida is like guess what the
governor of Florida Republicans said he
doesn't want the offshore that's this
one oh you guess oh go ahead of you